bonjour c'est simon à l'appareil
alors en fait pendant l'amour mois
parfois je pense à mon ex
alors je me demande si c'est normal par
rapport à ma copine actuelle et tout ça
bonjour point g je m'appelle maeva j'ai
18 ans et à voilà ben j'entends souvent
que les femmes jouent systématiquement
après les hommes comme si on était
programmé pour ça en fait les femmes là
ça prend plus de temps et des hommes par
conséquent c'est aller plus rapidement
et voilà le problème c'est qu'avec mon
copain c'est bien vers lui qui jouit
toujours après mois du coup bah je me
demande ce que je dois m'acquitter
anormaux ou pas on a merci pas j'ai dit
oui allô bonjour c'est pierre pour point
g voilà donc après l'amour je suis pas
très câlin à mon copain voudrais me
prendre dans ses bras et mais moi j'ai
besoin de me retrouver un peu d'abord
alors il me dit que cela n'est pas
normal et ça m'inquiète un peu
voila j'aimerais avoir votre avis merci
beaucoup
est-ce que je suis normal à la voilà la
grande question que j'entends tous les
soirs à l'antenne ou presque avec chaque
auditeur ou presque que ce soit 10 de
façon explicite ou pas ceux ci la grande
question qu entendent tous les
sexologues consultation après
consultation alors je sais ça peut faire
sourire mais vous tous tout au fond de
vous je suis sûr qu'au moins une fois
dans votre vie vous êtes dit mais
pourquoi pourquoi cette envie là tout à
coup pourquoi ce désir là et pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai fait ce rêve là et
pourquoi ce fantasme là et pourquoi avec
lui pourquoi avec elle et pourquoi comme
ça et pourquoi maintenant
est ce que tout ça est très normal
finalement à force moi la question que
je me suis posée c'est mais en fait ça
veut dire quoi être normal quand on
parle de sexualité devenir la norme en
matière de sexualité c'est quoi est-ce
que la sexualité peut être normal est-ce
que c'est souhaitable dans ces cas là
quand on commence à se poser ce genre de
questions le mieux ça reste quand même
un petit retour aux fondamentaux donc on
va regarder les définitions du
dictionnaire
le dictionnaire nous dit quoi alors le
dictionnaire nous dit d'abord normale
qui est conforme à la nature d'un être
d'une chose à l'organisation de cette
chose qui est habituel logique ordinaire
deuxième possibilité normale qui est
conforme à une moyenne considérée comme
une norme qui n'a donc rien
d'exceptionnel et enfin normal qui sert
de règles de modèle de référence alors
ce que je vous propose en fait c'est
qu'on prenne tous ces définitions une
par une
et puis on va voir si ça marche on va
voir d'abord si la sexualité peut être
conforme à la nature d'un hêtre ou d'une
chose si elle peut être habituelles
logique ou ordinaire l'aller point wc
charlotte j'appelle pour votre émission
de ce soir sur l'orgasme
alors pour moi l'expression qui
résumerait le mieux cet état c'est je ne
réponds plus de rien un moment la
sensation s'impose à vous à tel point
qu'elle éclipse to live un peu comme de
bizarrement cependant un éternuement ou
des chatouilles je trouve qu'on n'est
jamais aussi présent à soi même que dans
ce moment là
et ça peut même mener à des situations
un peu par la chance je me souviens
avoir réagi assez récemment un peu
violemment aux traits un orgasme
interrompu involontairement par mon
partenaire à base de je te déteste ne
s'est plus jamais ça bon j'ai tu
platement excusé après j'avais un petit
peu la honte de m'être comporté comme un
pet
voilà c'est ça le regarde c'est ça quand
même
entre autres merci et bonne émission oui
l'orgasme c'est cet abandon complet
c'est ce lâcher prise
total qui va chercher tout au fond de
nous et qui fait que non quand on quand
on aime quand on désire plus rien n'est
conforme à la nature des choses on est
hors de soi on est plus que soit on l'a
tous senti un ce coeur qui bat cette
boule au ventre ou les ailes dans le dos
ça dépend des moments
la pupille qui se dilate en tout cas le
corps qui échappent la pensée qui tourne
en boucle c'est parfaitement anormal et
en même temps c'est parfaitement naturel
les poètes parlait d'ivresse d'essence
la médecine la science a fini par leur
donner raison oui quand on aime on est
toujours un peu sous toujours un peu fou
en fait en réponse un stimuli sensuelle
ou sexuelle le cerveau va libérer un
cocktail d'hormones qui va agir comme un
produit dopant naturel on va d'abord
sécréter de la dopamine qui est
l'hormone de la motivation et de
récompenser qui fait qu a priori on a
envie d'y retourner
on va sécréter aussi quand tout va bien
des endorphines l'hormone du plaisir et
puis de l'ocytocine qui est l'hormone de
l'attachement on est en fait en quelque
sorte en sur régime
et c'est manifeste en imagerie cérébrale
un toutes les zones de la motivation
sont hyper excité quand cet état dur ça
s'appelle de l'amour l'amour qui est
biologiquement aveugle puisque dans le
même temps toutes les zones du jugement
critique sont comme endormi donc oui
l'amour est par essence parfaitement
anormal et quand on atteint les sommets
du plaisir
elle va c'est pire encore les projets
c'est félix alors j'appelle pour
l'émission de ce soir est il qu'on
ressent on quand on a un hangar où les
bains moelleux l'organe
peu tout sentir et tout ressentir c'est
ne rien sentir et ne rien en dire c'est
des émotions contradictoires qui succède
comme mythe radio s'est dit heureux suis
bien pis je suis triste mélancomique et
puis j'ai envie de rire j'ai pleuré j'ai
un guide c'est comme on l'appelle on
appelle cela un appel leur verse dans la
petite mort
et c'est pas pour rien parce que on se
sent vivant on pilonne avec l'autre on
est on parle plus de tel et deux mois on
parle de nous il n'y a plus qu'un grand
tout le monde peut pas arrêter
maintenant et plus rien ne put rien ne
compte
voilà on avoir un orgasme c'est un peu
comme comme mourir un peu
voilà eh bien écoutez parce qu'une bonne
part et et bientôt on va je vois que ça
parle à certains d'entre vous ce qui est
en soi une bonne nouvelle alors oui
effectivement
au moment de la montée maximale du
plaisir ça va chercher tout au fond nous
vers quelque chose de beaucoup plus
spontané voir d'animal une animalité
qu'on passe pourtant sa vie à tenter de
civiliser de domestiquer à coups de ça
se fait ou ça ne se fait pas là tout à
coup il ya plus tout ça il ya c'est un
mois qui est beaucoup moins nobles
beaucoup moins raisonnable beaucoup
moins lisse qui exulte alors oui ça
dérange ça bouscule ça fait peur donc on
va avoir envie de se raccrocher à ce
qu'on peut à des stéréotypes à des prêts
à penser à des idées toutes faites et
puis aux autres surtout à l'immense
masse des autres qui nous entoure et
dont on pense toujours qu'il savent
mieux faire que nous parce que eux ils
font du moins c'est ce qu'on croit donc
on se raccroche à ce qu'on croit qu'ils
font en un mot à la moyenne des
comportements à la norme mais cette fois
la norme statistiques et alors là
excellente nouvelle pas une semaine ne
se passe pas une journée ne se passe
sans qu'une nouvelle enquête un nouveau
sondage une nouvelle étude un nouveau
chiffre sur la sexualité sur internet ou
à la télévision ne nous donne du grain à
moudre regardez par exemple celle ci
alors 13,5 cm c'est la taille moyenne du
pénis des français
selon l'université une université de
leicester qui nous place cocorico dans
une bonne moyenne dans un classement
européen en tout cas pas honteuse
messieurs ne vérifiez pas tout de suite
s'il vous plaît on le sait il n'ya pas
que la taille qui compte et surtout ça
n'empêche personne de faire l'amour 97
fois par an en moyenne selon une étude
du rex soit environ deux fois par
semaine ce qui satisfait visiblement la
plupart d'entre nous enfin surtout les
gauchers oui 86% des gauchers je suis
gauchère 86% des gauchers se disent
extrêmement satisfaits de leur vie
sexuelle contre 15% seulement des
droitiers alors quel est le rapport
pas la moindre idée parce que évidemment
les auteurs de cette étude ne les
explique pas ce serait trop beau
revenons-en à ces deux fois deux fois
c'est bien c'est bien ab vous êtes
gauche chère madame je suis ravi pour
vous donc vous êtes dans les 86 % ont
sans doute alors deux fois par semaine
c'est bien mais peut mieux faire
regardez à trois fois par semaine selon
une étude cette fois-ci de l'université
d'edimbourg ce qui n'est pas rien 1 les
personnes qui font l'amour trois fois
par semaine par ace 7 à 12 ans de moins
que leur âge réel voire mieux que le
botox alors ajouter une fois et là
jackpot
les personnes qui font l'amour quatre
fois par semaine sont 5% plus riches
accessoirement elles sont aussi moins
dépressive et plus intelligente
comme quoi ne me demandez pas pourquoi
ça n'est évidemment pas donné
comme quoi ce qui compte c'est de faire
et beaucoup si possible le culte de la
performance dans lequel on a tous
plongés depuis une vingtaine d'années
n'a pas épargné la sexualité la norme
statistiques en matière de sexualité
devient donc celle du toujours plus
toujours plus loin toujours plus fort
est la seule question aujourd'hui ça
n'est plus comment c'est surtout combien
oui bonjour javel pour l'émission point
g comme giulia
je voulais savoir en fait il existe et
normalité dans la sexualité
alors il me semble que non parce que
voilà on dit souvent chacun son rythme
et et chacun trouve son équilibre certes
mais voilà c'est quoi un bon rythme à 2
x 3 x 10 x 20 sera partenaire atteinte
aux moches de comptabiliser mais voilà
est-ce que y'a un chiffre clé une
normalité
alors oui je vous entends dire moi aussi
j'ai très envie de rire sauf que je suis
sûr que là dans la salle
aujourd'hui il y en a au moins
quelques-uns qui sont en train de se
dire non et je les fais combien de fois
je l'espère
est-ce que je suis bien ce que je suis
bien dans la moyenne alors je vais les
donner ces chiffres comme ça on pourra
passer à autre chose
les vrais chiffres un palais pseudo
étude internet mais il ya en fait il ya
une seule enquête sur notre sexualité
qui soit valable aujourd'hui c'est celle
qu'a fait qu'on fait et chercheurs de
l'inserm publiée il ya en 2008 et qui
s'appelle contexte de la sexualité en
france donc
selon l' enquête csf nous ferions
l'amour neuf fois par mois en moyenne
ça va tout le monde est dedans bon neuf
fois par mois en moyenne attention
attention quand on vit à deux ces
chiffres baissent baisse est toujours
selon les chercheurs de l'inserm ceux
qui sont en couple depuis deux ou trois
ans et bien ils sont un sur dix à avoir
déclaré à ses chercheurs que donc il
n'avait pas fait l'amour depuis trois
mois des pratiques maintenant si on en
croit nos magazines préférés un que
personne ne lit mais que tout le monde
lit en fait un si on en croit les
reportages télé nous serions tous
devenus sm échangiste libertin pourquoi
pas les trois à la fois tant qu'à faire
on aurait tous un sextoy coincé calais
dans le tiroir de la cuisine au cas où
bref on y va bon alors pareil
selon enquête csf 3,6 pour cent des
hommes et 1,7 pour cent des femmes ont
déclaré avoir fréquenté une fois dans
leur vie un club échangiste en termes de
phénomène de société un on a vu mieux
les sextoys un célèbre hebdomadaire
féminin que je ne citerai pas titrait il
n'y a pas très longtemps
c'est vraiment la folie des sextoys en
ce moment et s'appuyer pour cela sur une
étude qui disait que 45%
les français utilisent des sextoys bien
faut toujours regarder en fait à la fin
de ses études là comment elles ont été
faites et par qui vient c'est toujours
utile parce que que cette étude était
menée par un fabriquant de sextoys qui
menait donc interroger que ses clients
et que les résultats éventuellement la
range on s'en fout que il reste tout de
même 55 % de français qui n'utilisent
pas de sex-toys on s'en moque aussi non
du moment qu'on peut titrer c'est
vraiment la folie des sextoys ce moment
que new deal enquête csf sur le sujet
elle nous dit que 78 % des français
n'ont jamais utilisé de sex-toys je dis
bien jamais voilà plus généralement les
conclusions de des chercheurs de
l'inserm sont sans appel pardon mais le
grand gang bang n'a pas encore eu lieu
depuis la révolution sexuelle des années
soixante dix
pas ou peu de changements surtout on
continue de concevoir ma sexualité comme
essentiellement hétérosexuels pénétrent
hâtive conjugale comme révolution on a
vu mieux sauf que ça claque - et que ce
qui compte quand même c'est de claquer
un faire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit parce que face au silence de
l'alcôve au mystère de l'ain tim pass à
cette inconnue la dent a la trouille
on a la trouille parce que qu'est-ce qui
se passe en fait pendant qu on fait
l'amour
personne ne le sait le désir est
indicible plaisir est insaisissable
ressenti est forcément subjectif
donc oui ça aussi ça nous échappe donc
oui ça aussi ça nous fait peur alors que
le chiffre ça cadre ça rassure ça normes
donc on mesure on compare on évalué
alors là tout à coup c'est magique
un glissement de sens au père et cette
norme qui était jusque-là neutre et
objective puisque chiffrés se double
d'un jugement moral et ça n'est plus ce
que la moyenne des gens fait c'est
plutôt ce que tout le monde doit faire
c'est à dire que la sexualité tout à
coup devient quelque chose de d'obliger
elle est ce que la société autorise ou
ce qu'elle interdit
et si on a l'impression que tout le
monde fait tout tout le temps à tout va
alors à la moindre pudeur à la moindre
petite baisse de régime on se sent tout
petit plus vraiment dans la cour
un peu anormal en fait ce qu'on a oublié
c'est que ces études ne disent rien de
nous y
elles servent à une chose et c'est
fondamental elles servent à prendre la
température d'une société à un instant t
en revanche de chacun d'entre vous elles
ne disent rien de moi elles ne disent
rien très franchement je préfère faire
l'amour une seule fois par mois si cette
fois là est une apothéose plutôt que dit
année par semaine et je pense que vous
serez d'accord avec moi ce qui me
convient à moi ne vous conviendra pas à
vous ma sexualité elle est à moi est à
moi seul elle est à vous et à vous seuls
pour une fois les sciences dites dures
sont d'accord avec les sciences humaines
les psychanalystes et sexologue les
neurobiologistes et j'en passe sont tous
d'accord sur un point nous sommes tous
comme programmé pour avoir des désirs
plus ou moins variées des fantasmes plus
ou moins intenses des orgasmes plus ou
moins puissants et ça c'est dû à une
combinaison de facteurs qui tiennent à
la fois de l'environnement de la culture
de la biologie de nos parcours affectif
ce sont ces ingrédients là qui font
notre sexualité et chacun va les
cuisiner à sa manière de façon plus ou
moins consciente pour aboutir un
résultat qui sera propre à chacun et en
fait les seules variations qu'il faut
prendre en compte c'est celle là c'est
les variations par rapport à votre désir
habituel par rapport à votre plaisir
habituel ce qui compte c'est d'être
juste par rapport à vous non la
sexualité ne peut pas être normal parce
qu'elle peut pas être normé parce
qu'elle est par essence et par nature
elle est unique individuel singulière
oui ça aussi ça fait un peu peur parce
qu'il ya pas de repères ya pas de
boussole on va dire que en gros à
l'intérieur du cadre de la loi est
évidemment dans le consentement des deux
partenaires
chacun fait exactement comme il peut et
comme il veut donc la question à se
poser c'est parce que je suis normal
c'est mais j'ai envie de quoi moi j'ai
envie de quoi c'est une question qui est
compliqué on peut mettre toute sa vie
avant de trouver la réponse et pillent
la réponse est peu changée le lendemain
parce que le premier avec la sexualité
c'est que c'est une matière vivante donc
mouvante donc ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui ne sera pas demain
néanmoins cette question la wii qui est
complexe wii qui peut faire peur oui qui
peut être douloureuse aussi en même
temps aller elle est libératrice elle et
elle ouvre tout le champ des possibles
elle est surtout beaucoup plus juste
donc évidemment je vais vous la posez
cette question là vous tout cela vous
avez envie de quoi merci